what's up guys i'm here in greece with
garyvee
okay that's what i want to talk to you
about yeah this is where i was this is
what i was uh i brought this up before
we started recording but uh you know one
of my favorite podcasts of all time is
how i built this yeah
and um
i know i know i'm saving it
for right now i know i know i'm saving
it
that was so quick
i felt like i was doing a channel five
interview right there
hey man you gotta learn i know i know
i'm saving good
oh did you watch his newest one on on
cue
the q conference no not yet dude
it's rough
it is so
good first of all but like sad you know
can't wait it's like the first interview
is this lady
i'll jump back to what i was saying
before but
after this the first interview that he
does is like this
you know like probably like
late 40s
[Laughter]
uh no i'm saving it
i'm saving that burp
do you want us to fly those out
no
leave them there
[Laughter]
lady
[Laughter]
we're not gonna make it dude
oh my god
lady
are you good
i don't know honestly
so is this lady yeah
and she's like
mid
she's mid she's mid
it's this lady she's gonna admit
honestly
[Laughter]
she's like mid-50s probably something
like that right so she's older
what she's like 50 years old but she's
mid yeah she's super mid yeah
mid 50s yeah
and
oops
nothing nothing nothing nothing there's
nothing
she uh what was i even gonna say
[Laughter]
i don't think he's good
i don't think i'm good
all right those burps was like the gas
that escapes your body as you're dying
yeah
this lady in her mid-50s
[Laughter]
he's masking out wow cash put his mask
on
no the cough isn't from cove but it's
from vaping
no kidding
no
oh man it's cold it's [ __ ] me up
yeah so i was rolling up
okay
it's not even worth it anymore basically
it's like the first interview that he
does is this older lady who's like very
clearly like midwest
you know
family like has kids and husband or had
them at one point and then like got
sucked down this cue rabbit hole on
facebook started watching all these
videos and now like fully believes in
cue okay and on cue and on yeah and uh
you could tell it's like really sad
she's like just talking about how like
how she's like worried for her family
and how they like don't talk anymore and
like
this lady essentially got brainwashed
and now she like lost her family because
they're a lot like mom's insane
it's [ __ ] up
wow yeah it's pretty crazy um
anyways yeah big girl honestly she's
that's why she's super mad
um okay how i built this my favorite
podcast yeah
so on the weekend they tweeted and they
said who
like this is a quote from the newest
episode who do you think it is and the
quote was
like
when i started talking about business
stuff
all of a sudden everyone all the
comments said you're you're the wine guy
you're not a business guy you can't talk
about business stuff that was the quote
and all the replies were gary vee gary
vega you know i was like all right i'm
stoked for this one yeah because you
know we you know we we take little shots
at garyvee yeah on our podcast we've
been known to do that yeah right
the uh you know he he embellishes a lot
he's a pretty exaggerated guy yeah we
poke fun at him sometimes right so i was
excited to listen to this because i
actually want to know a story i don't
know i don't really know anything about
him besides his like obnoxious internet
personality same
it's actually a really interesting story
okay and i like him more now they listen
to this wow
um
he was like
the
son
of two immigrants from they're from like
russia or something like that i forget
where
and uh
he basically he like started this
youtube channel was the first youtube
show reviewing wine
okay he basically like
like taught himself how to review wine
and how to drink wine and taste wine so
like
taught his palette all these different
flavors would like go home and buy a
whole bunch of spices like whatever
people said
the wine had like hints of he would go
buy that stuff and train his palette on
how to detect it
and then he he started the first ever
youtube show about wine
and that's what he did for the first
like five years is he sold wine and he
reviewed wine
and he so he's kind of like a
um he's a wino he's a what he's a wino
he's a wino yeah or no he's a what was
he called at a restaurant
a savant that's somali yes
like what they call them
uh oh the annoying [ __ ] person yeah
they're trying to sell you liquor and
you're like no get out of here yeah i
just want water yeah
that guy
sorry
he anyway anyways
he um
i i've linked one of his like
his like his show was called wine
i forget what it's called wine and
something
and he like he like brought it back last
year or something like that but it's
actually really interesting like
watching him review
a wine got it i wanted us both to watch
it just so you get to get to get the
vibe yeah it's not really that funny
it's just kind of interesting
wine library
yeah that's what it was wine library tv
i was going in for a second one okay
what do you what do you got gary
gorgeous acidity throughout this wine a
banana peel
meets granny
smith apple
mid palette huge acid on the finish i
still am tasting it
gorgeous acidity now why is the city
important
when i taste this wine i know i can use
it to cut through a lot of seafoods
scallops oysters clams you get into that
seafood it's kind of cool right
yeah dude knows what the [ __ ] he's
talking about or he's just making
everything up as he goes just like
everything else exactly which i kind of
think maybe that's what it is
great after shooting a pistol this is
the wine to drink after shooting
after making an example out of one of my
staff members this is the one this is
the wine i would drink after pouring hot
oil on one of my employees
nah i mean yeah that's cool
yeah that's it i don't know i thought it
was kind of interesting because i just
didn't know the side of him at all this
is what he did for like years and then
uh basically started investing
and now he's
a hard [ __ ] pivot man
so i was doing wine for like five years
then i became a millionaire business
personality
that's basically it good for the v man
yeah good for giving so yeah so i
thought it was interesting to see the
other side of him you know we see
the exaggerated the demented side of him
yeah
this is garyvee behind closed doors yeah
exactly
yeah
is he married i don't know
i don't i never know like i don't know
do you think gary i never know that
about people
well nothing
i never know if people are no people are
married or not i'm really bad at telling
do you think he [ __ ]
see this is what i mean is like people
like this where
it just seems like all they do is work
yeah it's like
where yeah
yeah he is married
there she is he
when do they [ __ ]
[Laughter]
knowing them they're like
they're trying all kinds of new
experimental drugs and
from different companies they're
invested in and different ways to have
sex and
who knows man yeah
lizzy today i've come home with a [ __ ]
ring
[ __ ] ring
and i think we should try it
she's like sure
nah dude i just had a bad one what
i'm trying a new set of edible oils
to put in your lady's vagina
i'm gonna go in for a taste now
what are you getting on the midpower
she's just sitting there with her legs
open he's got the cup
gorgeous acidity
on her [ __ ] right now
[Music]
mid palette still tasty ass
this is great for cutting through
seafood
i'm getting
i'm getting uh banana peel meats
granny gushing granny apples
banana peel meets goosh and granny
i'm getting banana peel meets fapple
a little bit of that mountain dew mix in
there yeah um
yeah that's that's that's cool i mean
i'm happy garyvee is doing what he does
now i like garyvee much more as a
demented deranged business guy yeah
his wine personality is just sort of
it's too wholesome yeah no i agree
so did i ruin it
what did i ruin no the lore no
because that was you know that was gary
before he knew what was inside him you
know what i'm saying
that is true when he unlocked that
second layer because you saw you saw we
saw hints of it yeah we started talking
about the business his eyes lit up yeah
the market the market yeah oh that was
our guy right yeah that is true
i guess everyone has that like villain
moment you know yeah where they
transition he became a business
butterfly exactly
yeah